So now we're ready to describe the conditions for
the logical clock proposed by Lamport. First of all,
the first condition is that if I have two
events, A and B, in the same process, the
first condition says that the clock value associated, or
the time stamp that it associated with event A
has to be less than the time stamp associated
with event B. In other words, we have this
counter or a logical clock on every node
of the distributed system that is monotonically increasing
as events happen on that process. The second
condition is that when we have a receipt of
a message, we want to make sure that the receipt of the message has a time stamp
that is greater for sure than the sending time span. So in other words if A and
D are the act of sending a message from process I and D is the act of
receiving the same message on process J, then
what we are saying is the time stamp associated
with the event A has to be less than the time stamp that is associated with the
event D. In other words, we want to choose the
time stamp associated with D as the max of
the time stamp that I see in the incoming message,
incremented by some value. Whatever the local counter is saying. These
are the two things that I'm going to look at and decide
the max of that as the time stamp to associate with
event D. And if the events are concurrent, in this
case, if I look at this picture here, A is the
act of sending the message, D is the act of receiving
the same message. B is an independent event that's happening on
process PI, it has nothing to do with this
event D that is happening on process PJ. And
these are concurrent events. So the concurrent events, we've
already seen this when we talked about the happened
before relationship. In the case of concurrent events, the
timestamps are arbitrary. Just by looking at the time
stamp, I cannot say that B happened before D
because, if I see the time stamp associated with B
here, happens to be four. Over here, we picked the time
stamp for D by saying that it has to be at
least greater than the incoming time stamp. So we gave it
a time stamp of 3. And so if I look at
these two events, B and D, D has a time stamp
that is smaller than B, but that does not mean that
D happened before B, because these two are concurrent events, and
therefore there's no way to know which event happened before the other.
So in other words, just because we find that there is an event X, which has
a time stamp that is smaller than a
time stamp associated with another event, Y, doesn't mean
that X happened before Y. So, while this
condition is an important condition, the condition that
if an event A happened before B, as we show in this picture, we have to ensure
that the time stamp associated with event A is
less than the time stamp associated with event B.
But the converse is not true. Or in other
words, if I have two events, and it so happens
that the time stamp associated with this event X
is less than the time stamp associated with this event
Y, that does not mean that X happened before
Y. This is very, very important. What that means is
that Lamport's logical clock gives us a partial
order of events happening in the entire distributed
system. So if I take any one process, I know all the events, the ordering of all
the events that happened on this process both
the events that happened sequentially in this process
itself as well as events that happened in
which this process happened to communicate with other processes.
In this case it sends a message over
here. Similarly by looking at the record of all
the events accumulated on process Pj, I can know
the order in which the events happened in this
process, in which process PJ had a part to
play meaning all the local events as well as
communication events that PJ participated in when it communicated
with the other nodes in the entire distributed system.
This is what the Lamport's logical clock gives you is a
partial order of all the events that happened in the distributed system.